We've come to the end of our course
and I do hope you've enjoyed yourself.
In this course, the topics we covered were
quick overview of the templates currently available.
We then explored the UI a little bit more
and how to access assets and placing them in our scene.
A quick overview of how to access and place materials.
We then looked at where to find lighting
and placing them as well as some settings.
We then discussed how to make the seasons change.
Finally, we discussed one of many ways to share your project.
Now Twinmotion is a very powerful tool
and there's so much more to learn.
There are a series of in-depth courses
which we'll cover more in detail
the various tools within Twinmotion
that can help you to achieve the desired look
and feel that you are wanting
to communicate to your viewer.
Until then, take some time to explore everything
within Twinmotion and most importantly, have fun.
Happy learning.